how to make an offer on a rent to rent
property even if it's midnight you're in
your pajamas and you've got your hands
down your pants so yeah so basically
we've crunched some numbers
and i thought i'd just bounce it off
here i can send an email over if you
prefer
with the breakdown
[Music]
okay so with your father's property
it's the eight big hmo so you were
asking for that property i think you put
that up for five thousand pounds
yes i don't i don't know if you fully
understood
what we what we were offering um we also
we also ranked your husband as well um
yeah he was yeah that's what
yeah he said he said he was busy he was
busy today that's why i thought we could
maybe email over or we could just tell
you what we were
kind of offering okay all right fine so
yeah do you have any idea what the what
the bells the cost of the utilities and
stuff are at the eight they have to
match
no so presumably would that be something
that we would take on we would pay the
bills and everything
yeah okay fine i thought that would be
the case that's so that's fine
so what we've so you're asking for five
thousand so
if you rented it for five thousand to
just a normal tenant obviously you'd pay
management of at least 10 percent and
then you'd have to pay maintenance and
voids and that kind of stuff
so what we were proposing was that we
give you a guaranteed rent
so there's no late payments um we pay
the bills we pay
management and everything and you would
get a guaranteed rent each month for
four thousand pounds
four thousand okay and we could
guarantee that for four years
no more than that well what we could do
is we could
after four years we could no no not more
than that
uh sorry you mean time frame or money
money yeah yeah the only thing is is
obviously if you rent it for five
thousand
i mean ten percent on that straight away
is
you know it's 400 pounds and then you'd
have to pay for the tenant fine fees
every time you find a tenant you have to
pay a fee
so it does get quite i mean honestly i'm
a landlord myself i always and of course
you've got to do what commercially makes
sense for you and your father but i
honestly
think you would be left with less than
that if you just did if you manage it
yourself so that is
if we did if we paid any more than that
we just
wouldn't be making any profit at all
ourselves
um so as i say if that doesn't work for
you
yeah just because that's what i don't
think because we did tell him four
thousand he was like i don't know we
want more than that but i don't think
he understood the actual well maybe he
did i don't know but
as i say if you managed it yourself not
only would you have the hassle but i
honestly don't think if you had a
letting agent
ah by the time you paid their fees every
time someone moves out you've got to
find them at the tent you've got a
payment
fee and then you've got maintenance so i
think it's a good offer for you
personally but of course that's for
youtube that's for you to decide
um the other property which belong with
the first one that we saw before bed
we could offer this the same deal where
we'd manage it we would do everything
this was the one that we saw you know
the four beds that belongs to mr singh
where we met originally
yeah that's the three bed sorry i meant
the three beds my apologies
the three beds yeah um that one
um same story we could take it on four
year lease
um and we could give a guaranteed rent
on that one of one thousand five hundred
and you'd have no management no
maintenance no voids over four year
period
and that'll be the exact same story
um so okay so perhaps if you wanted to
put that to
your husband and your father and then
maybe drop me a message tomorrow
and let me know your thoughts but as i
say if it doesn't work for you that's
fine but um
you know it's got to obviously be a
win-win if we did
it's a four-year thing and at the end of
the four years we could either extend
the contract
or we could hand you out the property
but again in the contract it would say
that the property would have to be in
at least the same condition as it was
when we took it on or not better
if not we would be liable for any costs
could you email over there please yeah
what would you like me to do your copy
of the contract
you know like
yeah absolutely absolutely if you if you
drop me an email address i'll get you an
email
over tonight great thank you very much
you're very welcome i'll speak to you
bye so what do you reckon do you think i
got the deal in the end
comment below let me know what you think
and stay tuned for more videos
you